[Música]
hablamos ahora de economía en france24
un espacio en el que nos acompaña
nuestro periodista jorge hurtado jorge
buenas noches bienvenidos qué tal maría
clara y empecemos con lo más reciente
del foro económico mundial cuéntenos que
se está discutiendo en davos y que un
contexto de guerra inflación y sobre
todo presiones en la cadena de
suministro los líderes de la economía
global tienen mucho que decir y aquí en
directo américa les iremos contando
durante la semana las impresiones más
importantes kristalina georgieva quien
es directora gerente del fondo monetario
internacional aseguró que la integración
mundial está bajo presión y que el
aumento de las barreras comerciales
amenazan el crecimiento económico de
todo el mundo la funcionaria advirtió
que las secuelas de la pandemia del cobi
19 la guerra en ucrania y está tendencia
a restringir las exportaciones oa romper
las cadenas de suministros mundiales
acabarían con años de progreso económico
esta fue parte de su intervención en
davos y respondía a la pregunta de si
habrá o no una recesión económica global
down mi respuesta va a ser no no en este
momento eso no significa que esté
descartada hemos rebajado nuestras
proyecciones de crecimiento para este
año en abril para 143 países esto es el
86% del pp mundial y desde entonces en
un corto periodo de tiempo el horizonte
se ha oscurecido estamos viendo que este
2022 va a ser un año difícil tenemos un
shock de precios de las materias primas
en muchos países y el shock particular
sobre el que quiero llamar su atención
es el de los precios de los alimentos
food prize shop jorge y ante este
panorama en europa ya hay señales de que
los tipos de interés podrían subir para
frenar la inflación así lo dijo
christine lagarde presidenta del banco
central europeo que demostró las
primeras señales de subidas para julio
en un artículo web del banco central
lagarde dijo que espera que las compras
de activos que impulsan la economía
terminen muy pronto en el tercer
trimestre y esto permitiría una subida
de tipos en 25 puntos básicos en la
eurozona los precios del consumo
subieron hasta el 7,4 por ciento el mes
pasado en comparación con el año
anterior
este aumento es impulsado sobre todo por
los precios de la energía en europa que
dependen como sabrán en gran medida del
petróleo y el gas natural ruso el banco
de inglaterra también ya ha subido su
tipo de interés clave cuatro veces desde
diciembre mientras que la reserva
federal de eeuu subió los tipos para
aliviar la inflación que se acerca a un
máximo de 40 años del 8,3 por ciento
anual y se esperan inclusive más subidas
de los tipos de interés en los próximos
meses por la guerra en ucrania y la
unión europea recortó su previsión de
crecimiento económico del 4% que tenía
para este año al 27 debido a esta guerra
y a propósito del conflicto en ucrania
un importante funcionario del sector
petrolero está diciendo que el
suministro mundial de petróleo corre
peligro en todo el mundo lo dijo el jefe
de la empresa saudí aramco que es la más
grande petrolera del mundo aseguró que
no puede ampliar la capacidad de
producción más rápido de lo que ya
habían prometido a mina ser jefe de
arango declaró que ampliará la capacidad
a 13 millones de barriles diarios pero
hasta el 2027 esto a pesar de los
llamados de varios países para hacerlo
más rápido y de esta forma bajar los
precios de los combustibles según el
ejecutivo la guerra solo desenmascaró
energética que ya se vivía por la falta
de inversión según naser las
restricciones de comida en china no
durarán mucho tiempo y la demanda
mundial de petróleo se va a renovar muy
pronto arabia saudi produce actualmente
10,5 millones de barriles de petróleo
diario o sea 1 de cada 10 barriles del
mundo y esperan aumentar la producción a
11 millones de barriles de petróleo
diarios a finales de este año cuando
termine un pacto que tienen entre la
organización de países productores
conocidos como la opep y sus aliados
como rusia algunos países como eeuu han
liberado sus reservas de petróleo
estratégicas para intentar bajar los
precios del mercado que por ahora están
bastante movidos con la guerra en
ucrania y la posibilidad de sanciones al
petróleo ruso y vayámonos a qatar porque
hay muchas expectativas económicas por
el mundial de fútbol y bueno estas
impresiones que continúan en el foro
económico mundial ahí en suiza el
presidente de la fifa dijo que espera
que este mundial sea el más visto de la
historia gianni infantino espera que la
copa del mundo organizada por qatar sea
vista por 5 mil millones de personas en
todo el mundo el récord actual le
pertenece a rusia 2018 con 3.500
millones de personas el directivo afirma
que la industria vive un desequilibrio
por ejemplo la producción bruta global
el año pasado fue de 200 mil millones de
dólares pero el 70% de esas cifras se
generó solamente en europa esta es la
primera vez que el mundial se realiza en
medio oriente será entre el 21 de
noviembre y el 18 de diciembre de este
año y ya lo veremos a ver qué ocurre
jorge ahora cuéntanos los indicadores
empezamos con words with ahí cerró
positivo mostrando cierta recuperación
frente a las pérdidas de la semana
pasada en europa la bolsa de londres
también subió ya que los impresores
dejaron atrás los crecientes temores
sobre el crecimiento global y la bolsa
mexicana de valores retrocedió levemente
debido a las caídas de las grandes
empresas
jorge gracias por toda la información
económica y nosotros seguimos en directo
américa con el debate presentado por
ángela gómez
[Música]